Building architects use sketches and
blueprints to convey the architecture of a proposed building.
Similarly, software architects use a variety of
notational devices called views for the same purpose.
It's well to remember though that an architecture is not simply a picture,
it is a set of these important design decisions made during
the course of thinking about how the building or
the software system is going to solve whatever problem it's suppose to solve.
Specifically, software architecture conveys the set
of components that will together compute a solution
to the problem while satisfying or not violating any of the require
non-functional constraints as specified in the requirements for the system.
In this particular lesson we will look at a variety of different graphical and
textual approaches for conveying software architecture views.
We will start with Philip Kruchten's 4 plus 1 architectural views paper which I
asked you to read.
And then we will add in some different views that go beyond what
he was talking about, the feature view,
non-functional requirements, bug reporting, context, and utility views.